but we just got the these sort of uh
urgent calls from the Ukrainian
government saying that we needed to turn
on Pioneer it's like in the middle of
the night well yesterday was the all-in
podcast Summit
they brought Elon in via Skype to
explain a bit more about his thinking
when it came to letting the government
use starlink or not use darling
the
uh around
um was actually turned off now the
reason was turned off was absolutely was
because the United States had sanctions
against Russia
um and we're not allowed to actually and
that includes Crimea in the sanctions
and we know that actually turn on uh
connectivity to essentially the country
without explicit government approval
um
who did not have from US Government so
so so basically the uh
look at you know Ukraine didn't it
didn't give us any advanced warning or
hits up or anything but we just got the
the sort of uh
budget calls from the Ukrainian
government saying that we needed to turn
on Premiere it's like in the middle of
the night they were like what are you
talking about you know are you lost
what's it for
um
you know and that
you know we're basically
um figuring out that this was
kind of like a Pearl Harbor type attack
on
um this Festival
on the Russian beats Festival so they're
really asking us for to really
proactively take part in a major Act of
War
um
and um
um the Ukrainian government is not in
charge U.S uh
people or companies
it's the last line it's the line that
the people applauded for right he's
saying he's saying he he says we we
support the Ukrainian people but they're
not in charge of America the question is
who is in charge of America at this
point because America uh as a government
the American government doesn't seem to
care much about the American people and
they want to force private citizens to
use their own technology as they see fit
and he did not want to create a Pearl
Harbor uh situation